once again and possibly for the last
time this is Ives taking over the Howard
Stern channel do not adjust your
settings it's really happening in real
time we will now perform our second
single from a brand new forthcoming
album soon to be award-winning album the
death of Randy fitzsimmers This song is
called countdown to shutdown it goes
like this
[Music]
all right
he had a ladder that you use to get up
there
and so it goes around the world a
million boys
foreign
[Music]
got all the facts got all the figures
foreign
please
shut down shut down
[Music]
shut down
down
thank you our thank you fans
thank you the highs
thank you